it's almost like a First World War
general you've got you're waving the
flag you're saying over the top men but
you have no idea what's on the front
line I'm afraid what we heard was
depressing and it was an exercise I'm
trying to scare you
European Union depresses employment and
destroys jobs the job destroying machine
a job destroying machine
it won't cost any jobs if you guarantee
that
I can't guarantee every person currently
in work in their current job will keep
their job thank you are continuing to
paralyse about the 350 million we all
know that it isn't that figure it truth
is that we gave actually more than three
hundred and fifty million pounds to
Brussels every week now we do get some
of that money back and it's important
and I was making this point to faisal
earlier to acknowledge that
my point is that I'm glad that all these
organizations are not on my side I'm
glad economic experts aren't on your
side well Margaret Thatcher said of
economist the great thing is that
economists are fine but you mustn't
inhale